bonjour mariana l'ops comment ça va
bonjour parlement ça va très bien merci
merci d'avoir accepté cette entrevue
malienne dans le 8 juin c'est la journée
mondiale des océans
je voulais qu'on parle justement de la
manière toute spéciale par laquelle
aequo mary se prend pour faire cette
célébration de la journée mondiale de
social il ya des vidéos il à
l'information donc on va parler de la
sensibilité de la beauté des milieux
marins mais parlez nous un peu de tout
le projet autour de la journée mondiale
de social on voulait mais on voulait
d'abord être quelqu'un
le voilier comme harris et est aussi une
équipe d travail qui réfléchit comment
on peut on peut faire rayonner le
phylloxéra comment peuvent faire
connaître aussi c'est un droit qui est
magnifique et unique d'un bal monde donc
c'est évident comme on aimerait le faire
8 jouer sous les voiles avec du vent en
train de découvrir différents endroits
mais la situation actuelle nous oblige à
le faire autrement mais c'est je pense
que ça fait partie de notre capacité
d'adaptation d'avoir a envie de partager
notre passion pour pour le fleuve
passion pour la dire l environnement
marin mais aussi dans notre volet
éducatif de parler à nos participants
nos jeunes puis aux gens en général d
importance
je dirais rester en contact avec la
nature
actuellement et surtout avec avec des
fleuves alors c'est vrai que la nature
pour ceux qui ont accès est vraiment une
porte de sortie au confinement
finalement ça nous permet de nous et
nous évader
donc j'imagine que c'est un peu l'idée
que vous aviez en tête
oui tout à fait puis s'éteint on
pourrait dire qu'un porte de sortie pour
du confinement de confinement mais c'est
aussi ses tympans d'entrée à une univers
c'est au pad entre un univers qui est
fascinant et qui est comme hier riche
dans plusieurs aspects on peut toutes
nos actions nos programmes d'études sur
le plan de tonnes nous permet de
découvrir qu est-ce qui est qu'est ce
qui à l'univers sous-marin l'univers qui
est riche et qui cache et quitterait
tout le monde le connaît et aussi de
l'autre côté l'univers des débuts de la
voile des univers marin et des
mammifères marins qui sont d'un flop
sort donc oui c'est une façon de pouvoir
sortir des caisses qu'on aime mais aussi
de pouvoir rentrer puis plongez dans un
univers à travers de vidéos il ya
travers des je pense de réaction et de
pouvoir dire que même si on
actuellement on ne peut pas naviguer
mais qu'on est en train de tout préparer
pour pouvoir permettre aux équipes qui
vont venir sur le bateau pouvoir en
profiter
est ce que vous savez d une idée des
quand est ce que vous allez pouvoir
recommencer sur le voilier c'est une
question a plus que 5000 $ on est
évidemment actuellement au nid dans la
volonté de préparer chantier il faut
comprendre que voitures bateaux qui
verne et il faut pour le pouvoir qu'ils
puissent naviguer il faut faire un
chantier et celle là ça veut dire que
les gens puissent venir travailler
préparer et reims tellement faire la
peinture redémarrer le moteur
ça prend à peu près de deux semaines si
on est avec toute l'équipe
mais évidemment avec toutes les
consignes de distanciation sociale puis
pour pouvoir respecter toutes les
consignes qui sont déjà on à transports
canada et c'est difficile à savoir si
c'est quand ça sert elle go on rêve que
le 1er juillet on va pouvoir maintenant
à pas depuis vraiment travailler mais ça
c'est difficile à savoir
on est prêts on est près toutes les
équipes sont déjà on a des gens qui sont
en gaspésie des gens qui sont dans
rimouski déjà des seinomarins de
toujours on a la chance d'avoir une
équipe qu'il a depuis longtemps une
équipe qui je t'offre qui a la
particularité d'être d'être passionné de
voile qui passionné de nature m'a même
temps qu'ils ont la sensibilité sociale
qui nous permet de faire découvrir à des
cellules absent l'homme nécessaire à des
jeunes qui normalement ils n'ont pas pu
avoir accès donc on a vraiment une
équipe qui a deux volontés qui n'est la
partie environnementale puis la partie
action sociale et comme harry c'est une
école non conventionnelles donc si
quelqu'un s'est inscrit à cette école à
quoi cette personne peut avoir accès
justement nos courses hippiques
c est comme un risque on est on a des
programmes qui sont différents il ya des
programmes grand public ou à ce que des
gens peu sécréter râler vit une
expérience sur le chat noir et ils
peuvent découvrir le fleuve avec une
dizaine d'autres personnes à peu près
une capacité de 12 personnes par par
kort et on a une volée aux six cantons
cosmique qui partira avec des
scientifiques étudient les étoiles où
pendant qu'on fait des études de haut
niveau de l'univers cantonniers avec des
gens qui font des études elle aille donc
on peut les aider on peut collaborer
avec eux au et on a aussi des programmes
de navigation avec des cadets ou est-ce
que les gens à un an à naviguer parce
que c'est une bateaux un bateau école il
aussi parallèlement on a un programme
qui s'appelle cabestan qui qui existe
depuis déjà cinq en collaboration avec
avec maintenant services québec est il
qu'on a la possibilité d'offrir des
entre cal à peu près chaque année on a
quatre voyages quatre cohortes des deux
semaines où est-ce qu'ils étaient jeunes
entre 18 et 35 ans puissent venir et
passent un séjour sur le bateau pour se
découvrir pour
pour peut-être sur la chance d'avoir une
future qui est différent et le fleuve
saint-laurent et les océans nous permet
de faire ça donc c'est ces programmes
sont très différents les unes aux autres
mais il ya un problème qui n'est qu' on
est très fiers qui est le problème
kb stocks ont réussi à avoir un pépin
cinquantaine 12 par k twente
cinquantaine de jeunes par année et
qu'ils puissent passer à travers ce
projet mariano quel est votre rôle très
sèche un projet socio avec lennox accès
stratège de l'action sociale des
communistes donc quel est votre rôle sur
le bateau aidé à l'école comme 2 c'est
une bonne question paloma depuis que
depuis le début de mon implication a
commandé une des choses qui m'a allumé
personnellement c'est d'offrir un abus
au delà alternative avec et expérience
ça veut dire que on à travers les
voyages qu'on fait c'est pas juste
d'apprendre à naviguer c'est aussi
travailler sur notre team de soi c'est
apprennent à travailler en équipe
si on a un temps de pause pour il pour
questionner est-ce que par par où je
veux mali et la symbolique de du fleuve
la symbolique de l'horizon les
symboliques de voir autrement mais par
intéressant donc depuis le début je
travaille à comment comment imaginer le
programme comment imaginer les types de
formation c'est quoi c'est quoi quand on
parle des stratèges grands moulins mais
si c'est réfléchir à comment on peut
avoir un impact avec nos jeunes que à
travers les programmes ou mais qui aussi
découvre l'amour pour les fleuves et qui
aussi devient des gens qui peuvent
travailler ma milieu maritime
on a dit on a des gens qui est
qui n'a jamais voyagé et qu'ils aient
jamais j'avais voyagé en bateau qui
avait jamais été sur un bateau qui par
la suite et on découvre des passions et
qui vont faire des études pour devenir
marin et ça c'est une des choses dans
lequel on est très fier on a plusieurs
anciens participants qui travaillent
avec nous maintenant comme comme matelot
en communication et tout ça c'est c'est
c'est sain c'est de donner la
possibilité à des gens de découvrir des
univers qui a jamais eu la chance donc
les univers univers de l'immigation
l'univers du bateau lui le fait de vivre
ensemble du fait de travailler ensemble
et collaborer cetc des affaires qui sont
uniques
mais rien de lopez toujours un plaisir
de vous parler vous aidant à cette
occasion stratège de l'action sociale
déco marines et déjà parlé d'un tout
autre rôle anna le cirque du soleil le
cirque social etc
donc merci d'avoir accepté cette
entrevue pour être canada international
une bonne chose si c'était un oui oui
soutenue du bon vent puis de la sarthe
et puis campus a amené à mener nos
équipes découvrir les hôtels
c'est ça l'idée je vous le souhaite
merci vous percer
[Musique]